thanks a lot for the introduction and
thanks a lot to the organizer and
everybody like the volunteers who helped
for this conference it's really been
amazing so far and also a great thanks
to all the people who contribute to all
the Python open-source projects that
I've been using and well there's another
disclaimer slide I am required to
emphasize that this is just a hobby it
has nothing to do with my real job I
work for and working in machine learning
lab of an online bookshop and so some of
this work is trying to work with
dannaker she was sitting there so here's
the problem why why would we be
interested in ultimate eyes they are
automating political party affiliation
or political view or bias prediction my
motivation for this was that everyday
media generate loads of texts and the
question is what should you read so you
could either just read what your
recommender algorithm of choice suggests
or you could just read what your friends
suggest in your social circle on
Facebook but that well you could end up
with following these rules you can up
with could end up with a lot of the same
information or views that's the
classical filter bubble problem and in
many cases if you're just following your
friends who happen to not be I mean to
to not be journalists for instance they
don't check their sources so you end up
with a lot of stuff like you believe in
chemtrails or Reptoids and that stuff so
the reason for me to look at these
things was that unbiased opinions really
need unbiased information and you want
to have an heterogeneous sample of all
the news articles with respect genes
with respect to political views sub
project goal was really odd automatic
detection of political views or
affiliation in general political bias
and then I wanted to a sample text from
an entire political spectrum and ideally
for me I that was just like a fun
project for me I just wanted to have a
news recommend that I kind of well split
stuff into topics and then within each
topic gives me a range of different
articles sorted according to well
political views say if I'm left to write
for
so some working hypotheses that I had
along the way were well it's a pretty
simple one can we actually predict
political affiliation from text and
another one that's almost the same as
can we predict political views from text
and by views I mean so by political
affiliation I mean just party
affiliation and by political views I
mean like yeah more fine-grained things
and I will explain that in more detail
later and these two hypotheses are
mainly motivated by the kinds of data
that I had at my disposal some related
questions that came up along the way are
well what are some discriminative
features that could potentially then be
used for well having political experts
check these models or maybe just
relating that to well the things that
people in political sciences know or
maybe use that for future studies or for
well if you read text yourself something
to watch out for and another really
related question that came up was
whether or not political power
influences the speech content in some
way so here's the workflow and it's
super-super standard its you've probably
have heard exactly that same workflow in
I don't know 20% of the talks the two
data science here and the reason why I
did it
that simple was just because well that's
what you do first right I also tried
more complex workflows and models but
they didn't really help in terms of
prediction performance so first I got
some text data with labels and I got two
different kinds of texts first I got the
texts of all speeches in the German
parliament that's called the Bundestag
and the labels for these texts are the
party affiliation of course you have I
mean quite a spectrum of political views
within a party but for the sake of
simplicity I'm just using the of the
party label here and I'm just looking at
to legislation period the 17th one is
talk and the 18th Bundestag which is the
current one that's still ongoing and
then I also looked at party manifestos
so that's what part is right before
elections in order to get elected where
they you know
explain the policies that you want to
that they want to promote in the in the
next legislation period and the labels
that I've got there are of course the
party affiliation to but then and not
only that's the second part of this of
these analyses that I did when I
stumbled over the work of the manifesto
project people which is part of the
vision shaft sentiment baleen here they
have an amazing project where they
basically took all party manifestos of
all parties in many different countries
for the last I don't know 50 years or so
or even more and they have political
experts assigning labels to each single
sentence in these party programs or
sometimes even sub sentences and they
have a set of 56 labels so it's a 56
class problem and these labels are a
kind of hierarchy organized so you have
seven different political topics and
within these political topics you have
subgenres so a topic could be economy a
subtopic could be pro market
deregulation for instance so yeah these
were the two datasets that I looked at
and then I just did some standard stuff
with it I cleaned the text computed
bag-of-words feature vectors I trained a
classifier just multinomial logistic
regression I tried other things didn't
work better and then what I actually
wanted to use that for I applied that
classifier to text worry I don't know
anything about the label and that of
course I just did that too well for fun
too
to be able to read more efficiently news
articles but it's of course extremely
difficult to evaluate and there is a web
demo for that stuff so if you're I'd
actually be really interested in I mean
yeah of course feedback on on this web
demo but of course if anybody gets
interested in these datasets which I
really can recommend working with
because there is a lot of work that it
ran into there especially also the the
speeches of the party of the Bundestag
when Daniel told me about this data set
I was blown away because you look at
these I mean there are these the German
parliament has four people sitting in
front of the Parliament and they take
note of notes of everything that's
happening in there if somebody insults
somebody if somebody interrupts the
speech that will everything will be
noted down with the name of
person who does it and what they say and
all this is made publicly available on
their web page so it's really great data
sent and that yeah
leads me to well the data acquisition
part so these are the the protocols that
I just mentioned you can just sort of in
the first part of the project I just
took it I just well scraped it from that
web page and I did broader powers on
myself and then at the Open Knowledge
Foundation through Danielle I met
Hillary Clinton back and he is a night
fellow he basically put a lot of work in
to make structuring that data that the
German parliament publishes so there is
an API from often as Parliament
that's a github project and there there
is a scraper that you can just use to
get that stuff in a structured form and
the party manifestos also those guys put
a lot of work into making that available
easily for Python so there is a RESTful
API that you can use for that I just
downloaded it from the webpage but the
API is publicly available and yeah it's
it's a great dataset and as I said I
just looked
I only looked at German data but there
is data for all I mean all languages
really I mean not not all but a lot of
languages so yeah data pre-processing
super standard I just did some NLP stuff
the most basic basic things you can
imagine stemming stop word removal
removal of the names of the
representatives so I don't over fit on
them removal of the names of the parties
for instance and removal of speech
interruptions like applause these things
so anything that's that I deemed to to
be um to be helpful for the classifier
to overfit on for instance yeah and then
I just transformed that interest and a
pack of words features it right you know
grams to five grams for for more than
three grams are you sashing or super
standard and then term frequency inverse
document frequency normalization and
yeah then I just optimized all that
stuff using grid search plain exhaustive
grid search using nested cross
so that's yeah I throughout the process
of this project when I started I didn't
know about any other studies that deal
with that kind of data now I know I mean
that there's a huge body of literature
dealing with that but it's a pretty
heterogeneous field many people come
from disciplines that don't know about
cross-validation for instance so many of
the results seem a little bit too good
for me from for my taste
so yeah I found it really important to
do two really well put a lot of effort
into this this is actually you're like
80% of the of the work is just
optimizing the pre-processing so and
these are the results so it's a pretty
dense slide so I'd like to focus on
there I am there's a point I like to
focus on the this one Thanks I'd like to
focus on on this part here first so this
is the results that I got from just
doing nested cross validation on the
Parliament data so I just in the
simplest case for NASA cross relations
itself three splits one part of the data
you put aside for evaluation later you
never touch that during training one
part of the data you use for testing
while optimizing your hyper parameters
the grid search stuff that I just
explained and then one part of the data
you just train on and this is when I do
this nested cross validation within the
Parliament data and I get well it's a
five class problem here for a 17-2 under
stacks we had we had the Liberal Party
the Christian conservatives here both
those two were the government and those
three parties the Green Party the
left-wing party and the Social Democrats
were the opposition and you can see that
well it's I didn't plot the accuracy
here but the icarus is also up just
above 60% so it's above chance
performance but it's far away from
anything usable and really and well
these are just the number of samples I
had in this whole doubt evaluation data
yeah so it's above chance but it's
pretty low accuracies when I when I do
the same when I when I test on out of
the main data which is what I'm actually
interested in I mean I want to I want
this model to generalize well to data
where I don't have labels where I can
cannot train on select news articles for
instance and the only out of the main
data where I can actually test how good
I am
is the party manifestos I also did the
analysis the other way around but I'm
not showing this here so when I test on
out of the main data the party
manifestos the performance drops like
really badly and this is expected it's a
different data set and yeah so this is
I'll talk about and I'll talk more about
that in the in the next part of the
presentation so what can you do to
improve that what many people have done
in the literature before they just look
at the binary problem Germany has a
multi party well Parliament but many
countries actually only have two parties
so that reduces that to a binary problem
and I also did that here I just reduced
it to a binary problem by classifying
into government and opposition and this
brings you in some cases pretty close to
90% also accuracy which is not plotted
here just precision Rico and f1 score so
yeah you can actually make the problem a
lot easier but what and this is also in
line with what some people found before
when you do out of the main testing and
out of the main here can also mean you
just go to a different point in time
compared to what you've trained on also
here the accuracy it dramatically drops
and these are the kind of effects that I
will talk about I've more a bit more in
the later part of the talk but so still
it's it's the same effect we do get
something above chance
so it's usable for some kind of
assistive technology or for speeding up
label acquisition with active learning
for instance but it's it's not like you
could really trust these results
so what so the question I had was why
are these predictions so bad the first
point here is that we don't actually
know how bad humans are there are some
studies on that but it's it's a
difficult problem and if you read text
it's not always clear I mean I wouldn't
I wouldn't have a good estimate for how
good humans are or just the spectrum of
how good humans can be so that's
something that I really want to look
into further and as far as I know the
people at the manifesto project they are
looking into this too
and the second thing and that really
relates to the to them hold out the 2d
out of domain evaluation data these
manifesto texts are extremely short it's
really just a sentence and in most cases
so 25% of the data have only 8 words or
less and 70 per-- fine 70% of the data
have only 17 words or less so that
really makes a problem much much more
difficult so to test whether the length
of the text has an effect on the
prediction I just aggregated all the
text in these out of domain data sets
according to the political topic that
the manifesto project people assigned so
I haven't used these labels the
manifesto project labels the political
view labels so far
now I'm only using it to aggregating
data to kind of denoise the text a
little bit and what you see here is that
you can actually with decently long
texts I mean it makes a lot of sense
intuitively right you can actually get a
lot better classification accuracies you
can get close to 90% or in some cases
like for instance the left the left-wing
party you are actually always get it
right well but of course also so you
have a lot fewer data points so you only
have third party you only have one data
point per topic and you can of course in
some part of the project I did something
in between so you can just increase the
length of the text but that's always
kind of arbitrary
it's also in line with what other people
have found but the tech the length of
the text has a makes it makes us has a
huge impact on the classification
accuracy now these are the results it's
just yeah that's all I wanted to show
about this so these are the results for
the manifesto code labels and it's yeah
it varies dramatically so here I didn't
have out of the main data because I have
these labels only for the parity
manifestos and some topics like
environmentalism pro or pro-democracy
those are well you can play around with
the thresholds to trade off position
against recall but it's it's not that
bad some other terms like Keynesian
demand I had to look that up what that
means and I forgot I forgot again I
think but I it's related to economics
economics and so those are extremely
difficult to predict but you also have
very few data points and remember these
are extremely short texts here there is
no way I could I mean there are ways but
I couldn't think of a sensible way of
aggregating these because you would
basically then transform it into a multi
label problem so to summarize this these
views or affiliations political bias can
be predicted with above chance accuracy
it's not perfect but it's well I would
consider this well a baseline that and I
would be really interested if anybody of
you guys yeah improves on that and how
you do this and also it's possible to
predict out of the main texts but it's
much more difficult of course and some
of the challenges is that well out of
the main prediction remains difficult
and short texts are extremely difficult
to predict now
I with the help of Daniel and then later
also myself I'd I try to put up some web
demos just to kind of evaluate
qualitatively whether that stuff is any
helpful at all
and the idea was just to expose
classifiers and then also to have some
news
well not recommendation system but it
just basically crawls all major German
websites for news websites and then it
is some simple topic modeling also here
I I tried every topic model and also
like nonlinear manifold learning stuff
for structuring the text somehow in the
end I used k-means because it just
worked best yeah and this is a
screenshot of the first demo that Daniel
implemented and here you can just put in
some text and I think it was something
representative something easy so yeah it
says I keep on neoliberal like I found
in the charged up which means rich banks
and neoliberals and danger the social
state and here you can also put in just
the URL of a webpage the text of which
you want to analyze and then you click
analyze it dumps it and classify and out
you get a party affiliation prediction
which would be here mostly left-wing
party than Social Democrats and then
green party and Christian conservatives
well it's pretty straightforward you can
also apply this classifier than to news
data and here it's been awhile since I
took this screenshot but the idea is
just that so here these different blocks
are clusters and I just took the well
most important words and according to
some metric to name these clusters
somehow and then I all the members of
these classes of these topics are news
articles with links to the Frankfurter
Allgemeine - beagle veld and so forth
and for each of these articles you have
a prediction that tells you the party
affiliation and it's not yeah so
sometimes it kind of makes sense and
often it just totally doesn't but that's
of one of the things that that I would
like to have feedback on I mean if you
have funny examples that that would be
interesting and and also if yeah it
always it not always makes makes a lot
of sense
this is the model that I trained on the
political view prediction problem so
it's a bit simpler and that's actually
still yeah it's the simplest thing that
I could do to deploy it but it should
actually be working and what you get
here is the manifesto code output which
is well it's a 56 class problem in this
pie chart here most of the classes are
so small that you don't see them and
then I deterministically derived from
these from these labels here the
political domain and while some left
right-wing binary kind of thing and
these can be interpreted as
probabilities so what I did here I
learned a lot about the language that
the parties used and this one here if
conservative parties talk about war they
don't say war they say security and this
is a pretty well it's one of these
sanity checks you just enter security
you see it's right-wing and it's well
and other words that are as good for for
checking one where that author comes
from is if somebody talks about banks or
big companies you can be pretty sure
that it's a left-wing person and of
course here the topic is economy and
it's pro market regulation and this is
pretty much the same as before it's just
some topic modeling and then in there
you see the single articles and the
predictions of the stuff that I showed
before sometimes it kind of works often
it totally fails but in some cases it's
interesting what what you actually get
from it at least you can get an overview
over the news and well it's all open
source and here there's this this is the
name of the thing it's it's derived from
fYI it means for your political
information and the demo links are down
there so the remaining time I want to
use to talk a little bit about well what
I try what I tried in order to find out
what this model actually did so
it's a linear model many people are
tempted to just interpret these
coefficients of this linear model just
because the number of dimensions fits
with the input dimensionality and then
they interpret these weights somehow if
you do this you implicitly assume that
all the features are uncorrelated which
is never the case for real data so you
should not interpret these coefficients
and there's there is a paper on this
that explains this very nicely so I what
you can do instead is just look at
univariate correlation or dependency
measures and I just looked at
correlations between the text features
and the party labels and these are the
kind of plots that you can then get so
here you can just sort positive
correlation negative correlation and I
just look at the top 10 or something and
yeah so those can now be interpreted for
each party if by political experts for
instance and also like laymen like like
me for instance see that for instance
here they the Conservatives talk a lot
about economic development or security
things like that and the left-wing party
for instance they talk a lot about
Social Welfare big companies the Green
Party talks a lot about army projects
they actually mention war as war not as
security but there are other problems
with the Green Party and the results
that's I think I haven't shown here but
there is a paper on this and you that's
also on github so to summarize these
disk remote if text features can be
interpreted by by experts
the Green Party for instance talks about
defense projects a lot they criticize it
mainly left-wing party talks about
Social Welfare big companies Social
Democrats about the rights of the
working class often Christian
conservatives talk about economic
development now especially the results
on the government versus opposition
classification and the poor performance
on on out of the main data that maybe
look at some other thing that I found
interesting sentiments of these
Parliament speeches and well the
hypothesis is that
well whether or not text has emotional
or I mean text has emotional and aspects
and the question was do different
parties have different sentiment or is
there a dependency between political
power and sentiment and this is
obviously a rhetorical question
I just took this sentiment polarity
dictionary from University of Leipzig
and then I just computed the inner
product of I mean yeah I somehow
weighted the text to compute sentiment
and these are the results the parties
are ordered from according to the number
of seats that they have in the
parliament and below I showed whether or
not they are in the government or in the
position this is from the 17th Bundestag
and you can see on the y-axis now the
average sentiment of a text and you see
the more seats I mean there is a strong
trend for fewer seats negative more
negative sentiment right and now look at
so the FTP well it's a very neutral and
liberal party as you can see but it's
still slightly positive look at this
party now in the next parliament FDP
will not make it in the parliament
liberals so it's gonna be only green
left-wing Social Democrats which will
then enter the government coalition and
look what's happening to their to their
sentiment so there is seems to be a
strong correlation between sentiment and
and political power and when you just
compute the numbers so political power I
took as proxy government membership
that's a binary variable or the number
of seats and in both cases you get a
strong correlation between well
sentiment of the texts and the political
power so when I showed this to my
brother's for instance they said yeah so
what that's super trivial everybody knew
this and then of course it I knew I mean
then I only realized it's the super
trivial result but at least it's well a
quantifiable thing right so it's not
just an intuition and sentiment is as
opposed to many other language features
very constant across domains so yeah
it's
maybe it's a trivial result but it might
be useful for out of the main
generalization so to summarize well I I
trained some classifiers on Parliament
speeches and on on manifestos and
political viewer affiliation prediction
works to some extent and it gets more
difficult for shorter and out of the
main text which is in which makes under
sense intuitively the discriminative
features appear to be related to party
policy and sentiment analysis shows that
more seats lead to more positive
speeches in the parliament which is
probably pretty trivial and government
membership also correlates a lot with
positive speech and there are some other
results that I found only last week or
so that show that in the Canadian
Parliament for instance some similar
effects it's a two-party system there
and you also see that a lot of the
information that the classifier is using
is not related to the political agenda
to policies it's more related to
attacking the other political party or
defending the well yourself right so
yeah it's just most of these results are
really trivial but I found it fun to
play with this and that was only made
possible by well the open source
community I used a lot of wild pandas
scikit-learn mostly and other other open
source tools thanks a lot
I don't know wait actually there's a
some outlook yeah so I want to I want to
of course trade on this is all work in
progress I wanted to train on more texts
and then yeah also I want to look at
this one here and if anybody wants to
collaborate on any of these I'd be
really interested in that thanks a lot
I did I did you can do that in many ways
sorry I'm sorry
Thanks so the question was so I showed
that the classification accuracy went up
by reducing the problem from a five
class to a binary problem I'm actually
not sure and then the question was
whether I could achieve the same effect
by balancing they are taking into
account the class imbalance because of
course in a parliament the people in
power have more time to speak so the
short answer is I did that so I saw all
the models I trained there's there are
several ways how you can account for
imbalance in your classes simplest one
would be to just subsample and then to
take make sure that you have the same
like a balanced set of classes or you
can also do and this is what I did is
just take that into account in the
regularizer of your model and that's
that's what I did it's just standard
implementation in circuit learn and so
I'm I'm almost sure that I didn't suffer
from class imbalance here but then I
also don't know whether the increase or
the increase in performance in that
binary problem like all going to the
binary problem is I mean chance
performance is also better right in that
binary problem so I'm not actually sure
how much better I got I didn't compare
that but maybe I should do that
yeah so there are many many explanations
some of these explanations I try to
highlight in the last part of the talk
the language is just different what the
classifier is using in and that was the
the sentiment stuff right might not be
related to the party policies at all it
may be just well I'm just trying to
defend this my party now and and try to
attack the government party and this is
independent of policies also the party
policies change a lot and this is what
we are looking into now with the with
Paula Lehmann from the manifesto project
yeah so parties write something in their
manifesto and after that they there are
the elections and then people have to
form coalition's right and when you
meant when you sorry Adam I didn't show
that but one of the words that comes up
really a lot in the so these Social
Democrats they often mention this
contract that binds them to their
coalition with the with the
Conservatives so a lot of the things
that they do when they are in power just
because it's a democracy right they have
to change their policies so it
necessarily will become different from
what they wrote but you know I don't
that's the only training data I have so
I
sorry can you repeat that yeah yeah so
the question was so there are some terms
like Sita height which is indicative of
or discriminative for for one party but
the question was I think if there is if
there are terms that are kind of common
to all parties is that right yeah so I
haven't looked at that specifically it
would be not very useful for
discriminating classes so I guess it
would just be weighted down by the model
is that oh yeah of course I mean yeah to
some extent that's taken into account by
the future pre-processing so on top of
the stock word stuff that I did I also
had some thresholds on the word
frequency counts if it's too rare or -
yeah and some of course some of this
stuff is also taken into account by the
tf-idf normalization so but I haven't
looked at that and specifically
yeah yeah so the the question was
whether I tried looking at classifying
single politicians because there are the
underlying assumption is that well there
is a spectrum of political views amongst
party members so there might be one
party member that actually belongs in a
different party that happens I haven't
looked at this but I did all these
analysis so these analyses were just
replicating what I did before before I
was using Hillary Clinton barracks often
as Parliament API but that API actually
allows you to do that kind of experiment
that would be actually very interesting
yeah and then just sent them an email
hey have you considered changing the
party yeah
yeah so in short correct me if I'm wrong
the question was whether the bag of
words approach is appropriate for that
kind of problem and I would I'm
absolutely sure that it's not so of
course it's a very crude approximation
to language we kind of try and get some
of the sequential or context features in
there by you is using engrams I haven't
to my surprise found that these engrams
are particularly useful so what the
hyper parameter optimization ended up
with with was two grams by grams so it's
not a lot of stuff that is in there but
of course due to the stop word removal
the Engram stuff also gets kind of
distorted so there are a lot of papers
that look into more complex things like
for instance you can do with just
standard NLP stuff look at the I mean do
POS tagging look at the grammatical I
mean the tree structure in the language
and all kinds of weird things and of
course like some things look like like
word embeddings would also make sense in
order to leverage suit I mean larger
corpora and just add these features in
there from experiments with other data I
found that this doesn't really help a
lot in most cases but it's an open
problem and if anybody feels up to the
task you know doing more complicated
models I'd be really interested in your
results
it